we got this from uh citizen Free Press
actually Robbie mentioned to us before
the show a clip from The Joe Rogan
Experience where he says quote on the
left they want they this want for war in
Ukraine this trust in the
military-industrial complex what
happened to you guys the best take on it
was Trump he said I just want people to
stop dying and that is somehow
controversial Joe Rogan hit the nail on
the head with the hammer with this one
the LA I was thinking about this earlier
the left and the right switched totally
switched you got this this Oliver
Anthony guy playing the song about the
working class lamenting the rich
corporate Elites ripping off this
country ripping off the workers and
these these wealthy Uber Elites in big
cities the highest income earners in the
country demanding we pay their debts for
college
total inversion before Trump got elected
we viewed the Democratic party as the
party of the working class today that is
absolutely not true vox.com ran the
story in 2016 the Democratic party
became the party of wealthy Elites the
party switched and now they claim you're
oh you're right wing is like okay well
I'm anti-war I'm pro-free speech I'm
pro-individual Liberties I oppose
massive multinational corporations I uh
corporations I think are horrifying now
all of a sudden the left
Pro big Pharma Pro military industrial
complex pro-war they go I'm not pro-war
I think we should Pro censorship
pro-censorship all of these it's a
complete inversion of what the parties
were when I was growing up well the most
Insidious thing about it is they do
control every major institution of power
they do control the administrative State
they do control big Farmer they do
control the entertainment industry and
so on and so forth with Silicon Valley
but they're able to portray themselves
as the Perpetual
Eternal victims and that's how they're
able to scapegoat Donald Trump as an
elite as the enemy as um you know
someone who doesn't have the interest
but I don't think we're in class on
their side I think so anymore
absolutely is changing and Paradigm has
shifted considerably as a result of
Donald Trump and Trump is doing better
in the polls now relative to where he
was back in 2019 compared to Biden sure
so he he's actually now winning it
doesn't mean a lot because uh between
now and election we got a year a year
and a few months it's an eternity
but I think what's happening in my
personal I can only give you an anecdote
I have friends and family
they're friends and family you know I'll
go to dinner and I'll be like you know
having dinner with my friends and then
I'll see their family members a year and
a half ago
totally on board the corporate narrative
yeah and we'd have these discussions and
I try to be very cordial I'm not here to
rent anybody spread look we're just
gonna have some macaroni and cheese
we're gonna macaroni and cheese I'm not
going to talk about this stuff but if
they bring it up
I'm gonna open the door and a half later
what are the conversations like now
they're moderate anti-corporate
narrative now they now they say things
that have me going like
how did you go from there wow all right
there there are these really fascinating
moments where after we talk
and I show them like actually that
wasn't true like don't don't take my
word for it like here's here's a news
story they go oh I didn't realize that
I'll be like look I'm not telling you
what to think confuse now a year later
they're like I don't like Trump but wow
did they lie to us you look at Democrats
in Congress I mean 20 years ago when
they are there were obviously major outs
I mean a lot of the political
establishment was on lockstep with the
Iraq War but you don't nothing in
comparison to what you're seeing today
with Ukraine I mean there were anti-war
Democrats who voted against the war in
Iraq obviously Bernie Sanders now now
you look at his actions today I mean I
don't think he's
um said anything critical about how the
Biden regime is handling
um you know they're they're basically
signing over blank checks to the Ukraine
over 200 billion dollars I haven't heard
a word of any Democratic Congressman
um who was originally against the Iraq
War criticized
um you know what we're doing right now
in the Ukraine they're totally uh a uni
party they're one step they're a
lockstep on the war issue and they're
obviously uh you know just a few years
ago Bernie Sanders was the one
criticizing the Koch's brothers and
their agenda on immigration wanting open
borders and so forth he was very
critical of that now totally 180. you
never hear him say a word about it
anymore the world or anyone the memo
he's not supposed to the world socialist
website called Bernie Sanders a
nationalist capitalist yeah I'm like wow
would we be at War if
Trump was in office with Ukraine I mean
at all not at all you think the reason
why I mean we weren't at war with uh
Russia in the Ukraine while he was
President I I take him on faith I
believe I know a lot of people uh don't
like it when he says you know I would
have brokered peace within 24 hours I'll
get peace within 24 hours but you know I
I think under Donald Trump we had the
most World Peace you know in generations
of any president and now since he's left
politics
um it's created a vacuum there and now
we have the most you know chaos in the
global situation and the global scene
that that we've seen in decades I mean
now we're actually talking about World
War III as a viable possibility we're
talking about
um you know using nukes again we're
talking about Russia and Putin
potentially using nukes in the Ukraine
to protect their own interests there in
that region so
um you know it's just night and day how
much has changed I mean I remember
Donald Trump when he first got into
office actually prior to even going into
office is when he met with Obama about a
couple of days after Donald Trump to
Face Time right now
we'll see if he'll call in we'll see if
he's listening but I remember Trump
saying that during that meeting with
Obama that Obama said the toughest thing
you'll have to deal with is North Korea
in the in the weapons they were shooting
off at that time you know and Donald
Trump accomplished something that no one
ever thought would you know that no one
ever believed would be accomplished he
actually walked into North Korea he
actually broke her peace in diplomacy
with Kim Jong-un Dennis Rodman too yeah
absolutely with help from Dennis Rodman
but no one ever Dennis Rodman
excuse whatever whatever resources you
can to to negotiate peace in that way
but Trump crossed into right actual
enemy territory with no security detail
incredible move I mean I think it's
attacked by the left board so this this
is it I mean
I view the left as fundamentally
tribalist and whatever we describe as
the right it's not even conservative you
have post liberals you've got a whole
bunch of liberals who are traditional
liberals who are now called right wing
even though they completely disagree on
a bunch of core political issues you've
got a bunch of people who are considered
right-wing who are pro-choice who would
agree with moderate liberal and Democrat
voters on issue of choice were it not
for the the cult tribal behaviors these
people exhibit I think Republicans would
win almost every election if they're a
pro-choice
I I don't necessarily agree with that
okay I think the issue I I I go ahead I
think that that the Republicans as a
brand have been so damaged in the
popular culture that I think that the
the Republicans overall probably aren't
going to survive another 10 years I
think there'll be another name for the
party you look at the way that the
establishment Republicans and the way
the Republicans they're very different
they want different things I feel like
the and because of the way that the
Democrats are similar with like DSA and
no no neolibs yeah but what I'm saying
is the the Republican brand in like
popular culture has been so damaged you
get people like like uh you know The
Daily Show every night every night of
the week doing everything they can to
discredit any idea that's a Republican
or died from a conservative I actually
be more inclined to believe the
Democrats are the party that will
disintegrate no no I'm talking I'm I'm
you're talking about the old the brand
name I know yeah right you think the
name Democrat will first yes I doubt it
because
when you first you there's a lot to
break down here right and that's why you
said when it comes to to when it comes
with the abortion thing if Republicans
are pro-choice no I honestly agree with
that I think uh the left these liberals
people vote Democrat don't have any
policy positions we we invite these
people on the show and then I'll say
like hey I'm personally pro-choice
and uh you know like I think there
should be how we traditionally had a
certain leeway within a few weeks then
they say you're pro-abortion or is it
they say you're pro-life they call me
pro-life and I'm like I I don't think
you have any real positions because all
you're going to do is say whatever the
opposite of what I'm saying is and I
don't see how that survives when you
have nine million Obama voters switch to
vote for Donald Trump when you have
Trump doing better and better and uh
Trump being fairly moderate this is by
vox.com standards not Fox Vox Vox the
leftist Vox website said Trump was a
moderate
what I see here is young men becoming
more conservative
it's it's more there's a bigger social
path
on uh forming on the right for young men
I believe this will this this will
create a social pressure on young women
to move right just like we see with
marriage I think for cultural reasons
like the success of uh the song rich men
north of Richmond the success of sound
of Freedom the failures of Bud Light
I don't think over the long period if
this trend continues
that Democrat is the thing you're going
to want to identify as because even
Democrats say they don't like Democrats
now don't get me wrong Republicans say
they don't like Republicans but
Republicans have actually gained tons of
ground with the freedom caucus with
libertarian candidates that are in the
Democratic party which gives people I
think more ground to stand on when it
comes to hey if Mitch McConnell retire
when when when these Democrats were
chanting retired Mitch McConnell Trump
posted it on truth and said yes retire
agreeing with them see I think that that
speaks to kind of my point like Trump
Republicans are not the establishment
Republicans and I think that I think
that the the and the re the reason I'm
saying this is because I think of dudes
that I'm like that are in the music
industry that I talk to that are
completely and totally isolated from
like this world right they're totally in
the bubble they totally like California
brain you know their entire world like
I'm the only person they interact with
that doesn't have the same political
opinions right and they have have they
it was a couple weeks ago I'm sitting
there listening to talk about like
satanists and stuff and it's like the
way that they think of it is the way
that like me and my friends used to
think of like Christians in the 90s like
they're talking about like they're like
talking about like if there was
something that happened that Satan is
like there was some satanic imagery and
CR and the religious right had kind of
got all up in arms about it and they
were mocking the religious right they
were they were going at him and I'm just
like I feel like there's so many people
in popular culture that still have a
negative opinion of anyone that's a
Conservative Republican blah blah and I
think people like Sam Smith that like
hit and and the imagery that he used and
uh little NOS the imagery that he used
like all that stuff is still very
anti-red I feel like the left still has
the the the popular culture thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at Tim cat dot com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time